this is the BBC London suffered further
heavy bombing raids last night welcome
to the mystery of information to film
division typically seems to think you're
what we need for doing what we'll need
someone to write the slope some women's
dialogue I thought it was a secretarial
post whose god sake you got yourself 30
million attend the cinema every week
your film must show your American
sisters that this is a war their husband
shouldn't be fighting what would you
think no screen credit notice if we
can't pay you as much as the test let's
give them character with whom they could
identify Uncle Frank 60s looks oh god we
all have a part of 90 feet in his not
this part the corpse Rory's dead before
the end of act 3 just a dash of humor
and then photos rolls me hello okay no I
dropped it a lot of men are scared we
won't go back into our boxes when this
is over the works good very good between
us
we'll have them weeping in the aisles
was the worst night of bombing yet
mister I thought she was under I'm sorry
I can't do this anymore
[Music]
given opportunities only because young
men are gone but to turn our back on
those opportunities will now be giving
death dominion over life
[Music]
girls like us we serve all those people
who gave their sons to one more
and now their grandsons to another
if all of this stop even if I were dead
I'd miss it unlike miss you
have you seen it all so I'm all flavored
sorry
mrs. Cole up where is she
cut could someone please get mr.
Hilliard out of Dunkirk
[ __ ] man a 40 years from now you're
gonna be on your deathbed saying where
did it all go how did we end up like
this there's a lot of seats